I have to ask you about Kristen Stewart
who has been so open and candid recently
are you surprised
are you proud of her yeah I'm definitely
proud of her I feel like I hear a lot of
stories when people are dealing with
kind of coming out in that way that it's
I mean it's something that kind of
haunts them for a while and it's a scary
thing um and it's unexpected and so I
think you know it was really brave for
her and I feel like she seems just much
happier so yeah and I love she like she
looks gorgeous
Ashley Greene has put her twilight days
behind her but still has nothing but
love for her former co-stars well anyone
from the Twilight cast be invited to
your wedding
um pens where I have it we're kind of
you know we're like a thrown around
maybe we've been doing it in New Zealand
where we got engaged so yeah there's
definitely some members that I remain
close with that I oh right I know and
hopefully yeah they come who are you
still close with um I think most most of
the time I talk more to to Robin Kalin
thirty-year-old got engaged a boyfriend
Paul Cory in December but don't expect a
wedding anytime soon we're gonna enjoy
our engagement like we're not planning
to get married anytime soon so do you
not see the wedding happening in 2017 do
you feel like maybe next year yeah
definitely not 2017 definitely before
220 but my if my parents will kill me
yeah I wait that long to get married um
but yeah I mean I think we're we're
hoping for sometime in 2018
any wedding must-haves we want it to be
outside we want it to be surrounded by a
lot of nature or than that just like no
drama no drama whatsoever and I think
that we want to have a really intimate
wedding and then kind of throw like a
big party mm-hmm after until then ashley
is busy wrapping up the final season of
her 8 E and D TV series row there
anything that you're kind of itching to
do next
um I definitely think I want to stay in
the world of action like if more of one
wants to call me has poison ivy been
cast yet should I quit for you
yes everyone put that in the universe I
think it was Kristen Stewart who said if
another Twilight book were to come out
she would be the first to read it if
Stephanie were to write another novel
would you read it would you want them to
bring it to life on the big screen um
first of all I would pre-order it and I
would read it first yeah I'd be
interested to kind of see where she
would go with it but like I just turned
30 and so I don't think I'm really young
enough to play Allison norlian
if they were to revamp it to have anyone
in mind that you would want to see play
Alice Ben way I always thought that Lucy
Hale would be a really good Alice we go
out for parts similar rights a lot
[Music]
you